c'est la première fois que tu as un coup
de foudre comme ça ouais où tu te dis
voilà c'est cette époque où tu te dis
c'est la personne avec qui j'ai envie de
finir ma vie quoi j'ai envie de partager
ma vie voilà mais le dernier quoi c'est
vraiment ça ça transpire de la lettre o
alors il faut que tu saches que bassam à
cascades ya dix ans en mai jamais mais
pas d'émissions chose de réel bah oui
c'est ça mais bon mathieu et alex moi je
voudrais revenir sur un sujet un petit
peu un petit peu plus grave qui nous a
beaucoup touchés et un truc plus grave
qui s'est passé vous avez donné une
interview cette semaine et vous avait
révélé avoir reçu des insultes et des
menaces de mort ça c'est un truc
vraiment qu'on supporte pas ici dans
l'émission et franchement ça nous a un
peu touché c'est pour ça qu'on voulait
vous soyez à ce soir parce que ou veut
pas que ça se reproduise qu'est ce qui
s'est passé en fait si tu veux jusqu'à
une certaine scène l'épisode ya quinze
jours ou trois semaines on s'est
vraiment embrasser si tu veux éviter
salue le courage de montrer deux garçons
sont passés avec la loi est un gros
bateau et cette image a dû fixer dans la
tête de ces groupes extrémistes ce que
quelque chose ils avaient en face d'eux
si tu veux la réalité et on a reçu des
messages mais on va vous veniez châtié
on va venir crucifier ça vous à tous et
ça alex après honnêtement on s'y
attendait un peu quand même
on sait que le monde n'ait pas choisi
j'en aurai qu' il ferait des
commentaires de ce genre
donc en s'y attendent les leurs c'était
bien de senna quand même c'était violent
dont c'était violent c'était quoi le
plus violent que vous ayez reçu c'était
il ya un moment donné c'était cette
femme qui a dit opus était une femme qui
a dit mais dieu est sur le chemin pour
venir crucifier
alors je lui ai répondu que je lui ai
répondu dis bien à dieu de faire
l'essence avant de venir
non mais non mais c'est vrai que ces
menaces à ce qu'elle vous ont fait
regretter un moment d'avoir partie
l'émission pas du tout cas pas du tout
moi au contraire je promets au contraire
et j'étais ravi même s'ils se montrent
vraiment les brezina rabot est si c'est
vrai jusqu'au fond du sujet